hey david do you think joe biden should
bail
on debating donald trump house speaker
nancy pelosi said that joe biden
shouldn't debate
because he's just going to lie she said
quote i don't think there should be any
debates i do not think the president
has comported himself in a way that has
any association with truth evidence data
and facts
she wouldn't legitimize a conversation
with trump
so i actually agree with nancy pelosi on
the facts
trump just lies he lies all the time he
insults people a debate with him
is a debasement of the discourse but
where i disagree with her is that it
wouldn't matter
because he is the president of the
united states and there's already people
who are trying to make the case that joe
biden isn't up to debate
that joe biden is suffering from
cognitive decline or dementia
and if joe biden were the one to say i'm
not going to debate because trump's a
liar
doesn't matter what reason joe biden
gives it would not be good for joe biden
now
the debate uh uh the the the institution
of debate
in this election could not be less
important i said before the conventions
i don't need conventions and i don't
need debates because it's all so
clear at this point in time but i do
think that there is a real risk to joe
biden if he bails
it would look bad uh and also
i think it actually would be good for
biden to debate
trump is not a good one-on-one debater
he'll insult biden
he will yell a lot he'll tell a lot of
lies but i don't think it's going to
endear him
to any undecided voters his supporters
will love it but i don't think it will
help
trump and biden is he's a decent debater
yes he's slowed down to some degree from
2012 when he debated paul ryan
but remember what happened with the
bernie one on one debate there were
expectations that biden would implode
he'd be unable to put together a
sentence or say anything coherent
biden did fine and he actually went on
to build a pretty significant lead
in democratic primary voting so i think
that biden is actually
fine to debate and again
you don't want to give any opportunity
for trump and don jr and everybody who's
been pushing it to
further these claims that biden is weak
in any way mentally weak
weak in terms of personality that he's
hiding in his basement or whatever the
case
lastly donald trump was able to do
certain things with hillary clinton
during the debates that he wouldn't be
able to do with joe biden
donald trump is gigantic physically as
you know he's a
very large man obese by any sensible
estimate of his height and weight
and he was an imposing presence
lumbering behind hillary clinton
although she was not intimidated by him
certainly the images
i don't think um were ones that
would be possible with joe biden and i
think that
not that that was bad for hillary i
think it would be bad for trump to try
to pull
his standing really close to biden
antics
in the way that he did with hillary
clinton so as of right now the schedule
is
three presidential debates september 29
october 15 october 22 and then the vp
debate which i very much look forward to
will be on october 7.
the last two presidential debates
october 15th and october 22nd
those are pretty late particularly when
we're expecting more people than ever
to vote early by mail absentee or early
voting in person
it is going to be more about turnout
than convincing people to switch by
october 22nd if you've not
listened i've said before if you haven't
made your decision already i don't know
what's wrong with you i want to talk to
somebody who's actually undecided
if you've not made your decision by
october 22nd
it's a very weird situation but as a
result i think that those last two
debates are going to be more about
can trump dog whistle enough to activate
parts of his base
and the answer may be yes we're going to
be watching them all very closely we'll
be live streaming
all four of the debates we've got a
great bonus show for you today get
instant access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show